welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar
medical cannabis therapeutic potential
and risks presented by dr. Marcel von
miller research director the Lamberg
Center for the study of medicinal
cannabis and hemp adjunct assistant
professor of psychology department of
psychiatry University of Pennsylvania
School achmed my name is Alexis Corrales
and I will be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before you begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation simply
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left your screen and type
your questions into the drop-down box
our speaker will respond to your
questions via email following the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the ask a question box to let us know
that you're experiencing a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. von miller i
will now turn the presentation over to
him thanks so much for having me and
today i'm gonna speak about medical
cannabis therapeutic potentials and risk
so first i just want to provide some
disclosures prior to getting started so
i am in addition to the overview that
was given before i'm also an employee of
canopy growth corporation former
employee of the Nerva pharmaceuticals
and a former consultant for tilray
and i also serve on the scientific
advisory boards of the lambert center
and the realm of caring foundation so as
we get started you know they're really
really the big question is what is
cannabis cannabis has talked about kind
of the
no large umbrella term but really what
we know is that cannabis is captures a
lot of different things and we really
need to think about these individual
components of the cannabis plant of
which there are many
so the cannabis plant we know has about
120 plus cannabinoids within the plant
THC is the most common and and the
majority of research really has focused
specifically on THC and highlight a
euphoric effects among others THC is
really considered a primary psychoactive
component of the cannabis plant but
there's a lot more to cannabis than just
THC second most cannabinoid second most
studied cannabinoid is CBD or
cannabidiol and the research in this
area has really been developing over the
past five to ten years or so but we
really still have so much more to
understand and that's just two of the
hundred and twenty plus cannabinoids in
the plant there are others then here are
just a few THC V CBG CBC and the list
goes on and on and the research on those
individual cannabinoids or combinations
that these cannabinoids is really in its
infancy at this point with only a
handful of studies really going further
down this list beyond the complexity of
the plant there's also complexity of
formulations so you know as you see in
this slide you know when you think of
cannabis you're thinking you know
probably traditionally on the top -
right the plant or the flower from the
plant but there are so many other things
and you know here's two examples of you
know edibles and extracts in so many
different ways you can formulate these
cannabinoids extract them from the plan
you know put them in all sorts of
different products and those themselves
have lots of different effects just as a
function of the formulation so it's
really again complex we're not talking
about a single molecule in a single
delivery route like oral we're talking
about a complex plant with all these
moving pieces as well as many different
ways to approach delivering those two
individuals therapeutically to add to
the complexity as the cannabis legal
landscape so here is a map of where we
currently are these are states where
as medical cannabis is legal those in
green are those that have recreational
and medical cannabis laws those in blue
are those that have straight medical
cannabis laws but beyond these there are
also lots of other states that have you
know more specific or nuanced laws as
they may not have legalized medical
cannabis broadly but they may have put
allowances in for example for CBD oil
for seizures and children and so when
you fill those states and in addition to
these states listed here there's really
only one or two states that have no
cannabis laws whatsoever on the books
the important thing and the kind of
complexity here right is that each of
these states creates their own laws this
is a federally illegal substance and so
each state is kind of taking the bull by
the horns and creating their own
legislation around it but because of
that there's lots of variability between
in between states so this is a cartoon
that I always like to put up and I've
had in my slides for a while early on it
used to be kind of a joke but now it
really is the standard practice right
your condition is serious mr. Reynolds
but fortunately escorts an excellent
weed that should alleviate your symptoms
this is where we're at right and the
problem is is that interaction is one
that you know is occurring more and more
but with very little evidence to support
it and that's really where we need to
build up the research side so here's an
example of what what I'm talking about
so each state creates its own laws as I
talked about before and has a list of
conditions typically for which medical
cannabis can be used the problem is that
there's actually very little research
and most of the addition of those
conditions is done so by lobbying rather
than based on the research so on the
left or what we have a decent amount of
knowledge about for which there's been
literature that's built up over time we
have you know what is considered the
gold standard in scientific research
these randomized double-blind
placebo-controlled trials so we know you
know a decent amount about THC and
nausea and vomiting THC in pain a
combination of one to one THC and CBD
for multiple sclerosis as well as CBD
for pediatric epilepsy
those we have a decent sense that these
are you know therapeutic formulations
that have been shown to work for these
indications on the other hand on the
right hand side are where the gaps are
and you know these are they vary in
terms of how big of a gap we're talking
about so anxiety for example there's
actually very you know while lots of
people use cannabis or different
cannabinoids for anxiety there's
actually very little literature I'm just
a few handful of clinical trials pretty
small-scale at this point that have
looked at cannabinoids and anxiety and
most of them point to CBD as potentially
helpful post traumatic stress disorder
PTSD this you know I'm just finishing up
we just completed the first phase two
clinical trial on this so again you know
before this study that we just finished
within the past couple of weeks you know
all we have from human evidence has been
you know a couple of you know studies
that have been about ten participants
each depression also maybe CBD might be
a helpful there but most of that is
actually based on preclinical work so
we're talking rats and mice psychosis
there's building there's a lot of
attention and interesting psychosis CBD
but may seem to be there this appears to
be therapeutic in this space but again
lots of clinical trials to go to meet
any sort of level of evidence of those
conditions on the left and then if you
keep going down the list from ALS to
Alzheimer's cancer cerebral palsy you
know we're really just scratching
scratching the surface and this is
really important because you know we
need to do these large-scale studies so
that we understand formulations
concentrations of cannabinoids dosing
and all of these different pieces of it
so that a doctor like in the previous
slide you know who sees a patient can
say oh you have X condition you know I
know that you know a combination of this
and this is useful and you should start
at this number of milligrams and move up
and you should be concerned about drug
drug interactions for this and this and
again we're not there for those
conditions on the right and that's you
know that's a problem and you know right
now everybody's going to kind of figure
it out on their own and you know an
important part of this is that the
placebo effect is quite high there's a
lot of expectation that
work for these different conditions and
so you know you need to do these trials
to really understand whether they
actually do because a lot of people you
know just from the hype just from that
sort of expectation you know can feel
better even though it might not be
actually that can have really farmed
formulation that's doing so now I'm
going to get into a little bit of what
we do know and these break down into
different types of research so their
reviews product regulatory research case
studies observational studies
experimental studies and clinical trials
this sort of gold standard and they all
kind of pivotal and playing a part into
you know building a base for
understanding here so an example of a
review this is one that was done and
published a couple years ago now from
the National Academies of science called
the health effects of cannabis and
cannabinoids and this sort of is a
synthesis this is available online I
believe it's free it's a synthesis to
all the experts got together looked at
all the literature on cannabis and you
know came down with you know this is
what we know for these different
conditions you know this is the effect
of THC this is the effect of CBD or
whatever it is and and kind of
highlighted the gaps that remain now of
course you know this field is now
growing so quickly that you know this is
already outdated you know from this from
this publication the researchers
determined that there was not enough
evidence or you know conclusive evidence
to determine the effects of cannabis on
epilepsy but then just a short time now
we have a drug approved at the dialects
specifically for certain types of
epilepsy trouvé in linux gaston and so
that evidence is there so these these
reviews need to happen often and update
especially with all the stuff that's
going on here's another one that i was
involved in that can be more specific so
there are some reviews that are just
very specific on certain endpoints or
conditions this one's about PTSD there
have been some other since you know
here's the literature talking about PTSD
and the different components of PTSD
this is what we know about depressed
mood this is what we know about sleep
this is what we know about fear
extinction etc so these review papers
you know that are endpoints the earth
therapeutic conditions specific
can also be helpful but again need to
happen quite often as this is a
burgeoning area of research then kind of
the next piece is product studies and
these are sort of regulatory studies
really kind of getting a sense of what's
going on out in the market
so remember cannabinoids traditionally
are not regulated by the Food and Drug
Administration so some people may be
shocked by that but with the exception
with a couple exceptions of drugs that
have been approved by the FDA epidemics
and rose and dronabinol
any other cannabinoids that are out
there sold and dispensaries you know
bought online they there is zero FDA
oversight currently and as such you know
you know a lot more about the Hershey
bar the pack of Doritos that you buy in
the convenience store than you do about
the cannabis that's being purchased
online for therapeutic use or otherwise
here's an example of a study we did
looking at the accuracy of labeling
right so really producers can put pretty
much anything they want on the label and
there are no standards that are enforced
in any way and here we found that 70% of
CBD extracts that are sold online
we're actually outside of the range of
of what they labeled and so in this case
you know we gave plus or minus 10% as a
margin of error so if you were within 10
percent of the CBD content that was on
the label you know we considered you
accurate and again 70% of those fell
outside of that so this is a real
problem you know there are some oils
that people are buying that have a lot
more CBD in it which is a little bit
less of concern but there are also lots
of oils and expensive ones at that that
have considerably less or even no CBD in
it and then there are lots of oils we
found you know about 20% or so have THC
and some in some cases decent amounts of
THC in them without labeling it right so
this is again a problem where you have
you know individuals that may be
unknowingly dosing or using CBD using
THC in these CBD extracts and you know
people can have very different reactions
or adverse adverse reactions to that and
that's why it's really important to have
that labeled
others so now as we kind of move past
the sort of review and and regulatory
side then we start thinking about
clinical development and really the
first stage of that are case studies so
this is kind of where all research
starts this is a couple examples here on
the screen of you know individual
observations or series of observations
about what's going on an individual
level so you can have an individual that
has you know had a bad experience or an
individual that tried CBD and had an
excellent response in a condition that
hasn't really the document before
there's a series coming out that I was
involved in looking at three patients
that tried CBD for fragile X syndrome
and showed you know improvements in
fragile X and symptomatology following
use of different CBD products and that's
sort of the first step you want to say
like hey look there's this thing out
there you know people should be looking
at this kind of an initial flare if you
will to the field and so these case
studies are really important for
documenting that on a larger scale
observational studies can do a similar
thing so observational studies can be
studies that look at a population or
look at a sample of folks and try and
describe what's going on again sort of
as a flare for where we need to go in
the clinical trial or kind of more
methodological rigorous approaches
here's a study that we did looking at
individuals with looking at veterans
with post-traumatic stress disorder
asking them you know how do you use
cannabis the majority here smoker inhale
what kind of strains or what kind of
combinations of cannabinoids do you use
you know the majority used high THC very
few people used high CBD and to me a
little bit surprising is that a bunch of
people just today they'll pretty much
use anything available so again you know
this is sort of a you know from these
data you know maybe THC is something
worth investigating for PTSD as an
example and this is again not the only
approach but this is one approach to
kind of get a signal of where to go in
these more rigorous trials other ways of
looking at epidemiological or
observational data is from an
epidemiological standpoint so this is a
study where we you know within the
Department of Veterans Affairs they
track
substance use disorders cannabis cocaine
opioids and feta means and you know look
over time at the prevalence of those and
in this study we found that among
individuals with post-traumatic stress
disorder not only was cocaine the number
one abused substance up through to about
2008 those that FY means fiscal year but
after that you see cannabis right and
this is again problematic cannabis use
which is the only thing that the
Department of Veterans Affairs tracks at
the moment increasing you know
exponentially and of course that's on
track with you know legalization in
different states so again this doesn't
mean everything this is just one you
know data point but another way to look
at these observational data so you're
not going out dosing individuals or
anything out you're just kind of taking
a landscape view of what's going on out
and then you can also do group
comparison studies so here's a another
observational study where again you're
not dosing anybody but you're looking at
individuals with autism some of whom use
cannabinoid therapy and some of who whom
don't and really looking at you know
what is the difference between users and
non-users and in this case it appeared
that individuals who use cannabinoids
individuals with autism who use
cannabinoids had improved quality of
life improved sleep anxiety and
depression and that was sorry just a
step back this was cross-sectional these
data so just kind of looking at one
point in time but you can also do this
prospective Lea so this is a study that
we're actually just finishing up a
prospective observational study on
cannabis and PTSD this is some initial
results these are not the final ones but
you know looking at what is the impact
of cannabis use among individuals with
PTSD so half the individuals using
cannabis at the start of the study half
the individuals not and tracking their
PTSD symptoms over time the caps total
severity in the middle is that overall
PTSD symptoms and as you see the blue
kind of blueish gray line being cannabis
users and the orange line being
non-users you see that those cannabis
users appear to actually be doing better
even though they started at the same
point after you look at them over
of 12 months they appear to be doing
better than the non users then you can
break that down by symptom cluster and
kind of see where these differences
might be lying for example in negative
alterations and cognition and mood as
well as arousal reactivity so again
another way of looking at observational
data you know relatively speaking easy
to conduct compared to clinical trials
but where you can get a sense of what's
going on out in the world and that can
help you again guide you where to look
right if cannabis users were doing worse
than individuals that were non users you
might not want to look at potential you
know cannabinoids it's therapeutic for
PTSD but in this case you're like huh
maybe there's something there maybe this
is something worth pursuing
coupled with the data on you know that
we looked at before on you know strain
preference and these sorts of things you
can see all these sort of data points
coming together like how to approach a
clinical trial and how to test this out
more rigorously so is this really all we
have um no but really the needed studies
are a pain to complete right so what
we've talked about are kind of the easy
easier stuff it's not easy by any
stretch of the imagination but once you
start moving from B's observational
epidemiological product safety and
review studies into the clinical trial
space it gets significantly more
challenging and that reason for that is
because cannabis in most preparations is
remains federally in the bullets at DEA
Schedule one drug and that means that
any clinical trials again with the
couple exceptions and right now more
recently with the FarmVille with the
exception of hemp derived CBD that is
you know less than point zero three
percent THC is that is the definition of
it with the exception of that you know
you're studying THC you're studying a
one-to-one combination of THC and CBD
you're studying any sort of other
variations they are even CBD that
synthetically derived anything in that
your schedule one and you remain in
schedule one meaning that each site has
to have a schedule and license from the
DEA the DEA has pre strict oversight
into the production all the way through
to dispensing of the products there's
specific applications that each site and
the clinical trial has to do safe
that the product has to be stored in in
some cases bolted to the floor with
special inspections and security and
then there's also limitations on where
you can get the product from if you want
botanical products you have to get it
from the National Institutes and drug
abuse or you could get it from some
pharmaceutical companies but it would
have to be their pharmaceutical product
or you can synthetically manufacture it
so again this is within the United
States this is an issue other countries
have very different rules and
regulations so it's easier to conduct
trials for example in Australia or in
Canada because they don't have the same
scheduling of cannabis or THC and so you
know with these hoops these are not
barriers these are really hoops that
drag the process out you know it makes
it difficult and and kind of aversive
for some folks to engage and so a lot of
researchers have kind of stayed out of
it or done research in other countries
so you know but there are some folks
that do do this work within the United
States so here's sort of a poll just to
kind of keep it a little bit engaging so
under what schedule so this is the DEA
scheduling does THC fall so Schedule one
schedule - schedule three all of the
above or none of the above the answer
really is all of the above and this is
what's sort of sort of crazy from the
DEA perspective is that th see if it's
derived from the cannabis plant remains
in schedule one if THC is is taken from
a pharmaceutical company it's
specifically sinned rose
so manufactured by incest
pharmaceuticals that is scheduled - and
dronabinol or Marinol is Schedule three
even though we're all talking about THC
it's the exact same molecule exact same
structure and it's in three different
schedules just as a function of where it
comes from and so this is again where
the complexity and the confusion comes
in it can really be a nightmare to do
these clinical trials here's the DEA
federal law scheduling here and you see
marijuana as a schedule 1 during a ban
on an oral solution this is syndra's as
schedule 2 and then dronabinol synthetic
and sesame oil as which is marinol and
in schedule 3
CBD similarly and it's just getting a
lot more confusing here so CBD you know
does it fall on schedule two three four
all of the above or none of the above
and the answer is none of the above
right so CBD is Schedule one if it's
synthetically manufactured if it comes
from cannabis its schedule five in the
preparation of epidemics which is you
know suspended in sesame oil or if it
comes from heme its unscheduled as of
the farm bill so again very confusing
landscape to navigate and again we're
talking the exact same molecule CBD
that's found in the plant and CBD that's
synthetically manufactured in this
example is exactly the same but it's
completely different in terms of
scheduling so the bright side so I'm
going to give you a little bit of an
example of some of the cool experimental
and clinical work that's going on in the
space for those that have plotted along
and done this work both within and
outside the United States so here's a
study about my colleague Ryan band REE
who does experimental work and this is
looking at THC administration twenty
five so individuals that are given
twenty five milligrams of THC either by
smoke vape or oral administration and
what you see here is so on the left side
this is their blood concentration so
when they smoke or vape THC at 25
milligrams they get a very quick peak
effect so all the way up you know for
vaping up to fourteen nanograms per ml
and then you know very quickly that kind
of dissipates and by our three or so
their blood level is below two nanograms
per ml on the other hand and oral
administration you see a much more
delayed effect right and a much lower
nanogram per ml peak blood so this is
kind of a cool way to do experimental
research I think Ryan ban who's probably
one of the more cutting-edge in the
space of looking at the you know
administering these within a lab and
looking at the impact of different
routes of administration and outcomes on
the right hand side are drug effects so
you know individuals that are reporting
how high they feel and again you see you
know individuals that smoker
having a very quick effect kind of
following the blood pretty similarly a
little bit longer delay to returning to
baseline but an oral administration you
see almost a peak you know a delay again
but almost a peak effect similar to
smoking and vaping but if you look back
at the blood level the blood levels way
lower right and so here you have an
individual that may not test positive
right almost has you know has very
little blood THC but it has a similar
subjective effect of an individual that
smoked or baked so again these nuances
are really important to learn about and
to determine and this is really where
some really fascinating work is going on
from the experimental side and then
their clinical trials so as you move
through these more traditional phase 2
phase 3 clinical trials this is one with
epidural x that was published a few
years back and this was a an open-label
study where individuals were enrolled
all given epidural x and you know took a
look at what the impact was on their
seizures what their side effects were so
you see here somnolence decreased
appetite diarrhea fatigue is some side
effects that were that were identified
and you know on the bottom right you see
seizure frequency and so you can see
this decrease in Seashore frequency over
time over the course of 12 weeks
everybody knew they were getting the
drug but you kind of look at this in an
open-label trial that's how it's
typically done but you look at this sort
of change and seizure frequency in this
case outcome over the course of 12 weeks
or whatever makes sense within your
endpoint here's another study this is
kind of on the flip side looking at
consequences this is a study looking at
dronabinol for the treatment of cannabis
dependence so there are some individuals
that have problems associated with their
cannabis use and this is a randomized
double-blind placebo-controlled trial
looking at you know individuals to take
dronov and also that synthetic THC that
we talked about before and its impact on
symptoms of withdrawal from cannabis
dependence so dynamite grass right well
it's a little more nuanced than that and
I'm just
totte touch a little bit at the end here
about consequences in some future
directions so really it's not all
gumdrops and lollipops there are some
consequences associated with this some
of these are controversial a little bit
some of them are not these are you know
some of the more common ones short term
use of particularly THC has been
associated with impaired short-term
memory motor coordination altered
judgment some paranoia and psychosis
again from short term use
and long term use has been pretty
established that this causes addiction
or dependence for adolescents brain
development can be altered and so really
try to avoid high doses or long term use
of THC in adolescence or childhood
because there's been some downstream
effects on that then you know some of
these others you can you know there's
been some pushback a little poor
educational outcome cognitive impairment
diminished life satisfaction achievement
symptoms of chronic bronchitis and you
know this last one is kind of you know I
said I kind of focus on the first two
and the last one is really the strongest
evidence you know the last one being
individuals that have a risk for
schizophrenia and psychosis a you know a
genetic risk factor family history etc
are at increased risk if they're using
THC of developing such disorders so just
really important things to think about
you know it is you know while use can
have its benefits you know particularly
use of THC repeated use frequent use for
a long period of time can lead to
consequences it can lead to difficulties
quitting you can even lead to altered
brain development if it's started too
early and it can lead to risk of chronic
risk of psychosis but where
schizophrenia among those with
vulnerabilities so here's a an example
of this sort of the consequence aside
from an observational standpoint this
was a study in a medical cannabis
dispensary among adults where
individuals self reported on
symptomatology briefly is about 217
people majority white this was conducted
in the San Francisco Bay Area and
there's just some background again on
education marital status cetera
the top ten reasons why individuals
reported using medical cannabis was
anxiety chronic pain all the way down
through post-traumatic stress disorder
what you can notice here is that the
percentages overlap right so very these
are individuals that are using for
multiple reasons right there's this
doesn't just add up to a hundred percent
you have people that are using for
anxiety and chronic pain and depression
or whatever else and typically you know
they've been lots of studies since this
one but most of them find anxiety and
chronic pain one or the other they kind
of flip-flop for the number one
condition why individuals use medical
cannabis and then we looked at abuse
independence so let's look at negative
consequences as a function of each of
these different conditions and we see
you know a decent number of folks you
know folks that are using for anxiety
folks that are using from PTSD and all
the way through our meeting criteria we
did a diagnostic assessment these these
are individuals that are meeting
criteria for substance abuse meeting
criteria for cannabis dependence you
know so this is you know an important
consideration a lot of people say oh
this is not a big deal well you know it
is and you know while a lot of people
might not be dependent on the drug there
are a few that do and a lot of people
don't even know that they can have
problems with dependence or you know
have difficulty quitting because they've
never tried you know this you know
characteristic of dependence is you know
to increased tolerance needing to use
more and more to get the same effect
craving during times that you're not
using you know when you stop having
withdrawal symptoms and these withdrawal
symptoms last quite some time so again
important to think about within this are
these negative consequences and to track
them another study here this is a study
looking at individuals with PTSD would
in all the individuals with cannabis use
disorder you know dependent cannabis use
some with PTSD some without and again we
find you know individuals with PTSD may
be at higher risk these are individuals
that are more likely to use for coping
reasons more likely to have withdrawal
during discontinuation more likely to
crave during times
that they're not using and so these are
the sorts of things that are important
to track not just in the general
populations we saw before but also some
certain specialized populations may be
particularly at risk if one were to go
down the path on these negative
consequences of quitting or attempting
treatment it's pretty difficult
you know our treatments for cannabis use
problems or heavy cannabis use are not
that great relapse is very common you
know among about 63% of people receiving
motivational enhancement or motivational
interviewing and cognitive behavioral
therapy so these are two treatments
which we'll talk about in the second
relapse within four months seventy-two
percent by six months among in another
study among cannabis dependent
outpatients you know we see up to 71%
lapsing within six months so that's
using again so again these are people
that are you know a subset of the
population that really want to stop
using have difficulties using and
they're not that successful this is some
of our best treatments red cognitive
behavioral therapy Green contingency
management and yellow cognitive
behavioral therapy plus contingency
management so these are sort of a
traditional behavioral approach to
treatment as well as contingency
management which is sort of like
providing incentives for sustained
periods of abstinence and you see in
this study you know just out of the door
or ET ex being end of treatment rates
are not that great and as we look out
six months nine months twelve months you
know these precipitously drop regardless
of treatment though the combination
appears to be a little bit better
these are not great numbers and shows
kind of where from a treatment
perspective we have difficulties it's
can you look at predictors of relapse so
why is it that individuals are stopping
are having difficulty stopping low
levels of physical activity poor sleep
and positive expectancies you know if
you think this is great it's really
helpful for you of course you're gonna
have difficulty when you stop so there's
you know there's a whole line of
research that looks at this picked this
piece you know how can we predict
individuals that are going to have
problems with use how are we going to
help them quit and how are we going to
identify those folks that are most
vulnerable
- relapsing during put attempts here's a
study that we did is looking exactly at
that so orange line is PTSD diagnosis
white line is no PTSD diagnosis these
are all folks that have a cannabis use
disorder and we're really looking here
to see all right individuals that are
interested in quitting they stopped
using and we follow them over time to
see how likely they are to relapse or
use cannabis at all and this is just
looking at using cannabis at all and we
find that the individuals with PTSD for
the first four weeks or so which kind of
maps on to the time period of which
cannabis withdrawal is most salient they
have you know they're using more
cannabis than the non users though they
appear to catch up over time so let's
look at the clinical landscape and
implications you know as we start
stepping back so that's the kind of
negative consequences where does this
all kind of connect together is patient
care right we really need to understand
this from a patient care perspective and
here's one study where we looked at
physicians right so what do physicians
think of all this and this was really
asking physicians about what they think
about cannabis in terms of
post-traumatic stress disorder and
anxiety so some of those top two of
those top ten conditions that we talked
about before that individuals use
medical cannabis for this is the kind of
breakdown of the sample and this is
probably a terrible chart but really
this is you know something you know
because of these gaps because of the
gaps in in terms of what we know
therapeutically the fact that we still
need to figure out a lot in terms of
dosing and couple with that the negative
consequences that are definitely a real
risk particularly among heavy users of
THC you have a lot of individuals a lot
of physicians on that's at that space
that don't believe it's safe to use
cannabis for these conditions and you
know and are very unlikely if you see
kind of towards the bottom prescribing
cannabis for PTSD or writing a
recommendation right never or not at all
as the majority of these physicians
because again the data aren't there and
while there are lots of individuals that
believe you know and have personal
experiences and
you know we really need to bridge this
gap or else physicians are not going to
do it right physicians are used to
traditional medication where they need
to know exactly what the formulation is
we know we know the consistency of the
product over time you know that it's
safe to administer you know how much to
administer and over what period of time
and you know what drugs drug drug
interactions there are to be careful of
so again you know that coupled with the
negative consequences which are real for
some for any drug right and including
cannabis you know you see hesitancy from
the physician side in terms of engaging
in this study we looked at you know this
is kind of plays it out right so in the
previous study we saw that a lot of
sorry to give bad conduct for so the
second from the top conducting formal
assessments of cannabis user problems
you know half of the individuals or the
physicians really don't even assess for
problems and again this is where the
knowledge base is translates is to
medical records so this is a study where
we looked at all individuals that we
identified as having a cannabis use
disorder in this particular group so
that's the hundred percent on the white
bar on the left so we you know this is a
group of all people that have problems
with cannabis use and you look in their
medical records and only 23 percent of
them have that identified in their
medical records at all so again this is
that gap if you're not assessing as a
clinician for problems associated with
the use we're not able to track right
from a meta-level what's going on and be
able to assign treatments or no
treatment need across a healthcare
system and so ways of doing that i'm
ways of intervening are you know very
simple you know you don't have to do
full-on full-blown assessments there are
little things that can help you get an
idea this is a great instrument
developed what nine years ago now by
Simon Adamson eight questions called the
cannabis use disorder identification
test revised eight questions people fill
it out and with a pretty decent accuracy
it can identify individuals that have
problems associated with use we then
thought well eight questions might be
too long right there are lots of
settings like primary care you see the
doctor for two seconds you see an intake
for two seconds so we narrowed it down
to three questions
and now you know in three questions
similarly similar sort of ability to
detect problematic use three questions
we can get a score we have a cut-off
score here you know for this measure two
or higher you know it's much better than
flipping a coin you can you know with a
score of two or higher from this you can
really identify people that are likely
to need some intervention or have some
problems with use so again important
things from a clinical standpoint and
how these the rubber meets the road here
and then finally from a treatment
approach you know we talked about
cognitive behavioral therapy
motivational interviewing contingency
management and but you know learning
from from a treatment perspective those
problems that subgroups have so we
looked at that PTSD graph and we saw
that you know individual PTSD at least
for the first four weeks had greater
difficulty than those without PTSD maybe
from a different study that that was
because they had more craving or
withdrawal then you know there are
treatments that have now come up
recently this is one by suni back
specifically targeting these
subpopulations and this is a concurrent
treatment for post-traumatic stress
disorder and substance use disorders
like you know hone in on these
populations that are greatest need and
figure out treatments for them so
instead of leaving on a negative note
let's talk about a positive note so
where are we going from here this is
pretty much the end of the talk just a
couple of quick slides on future studies
that are coming up I mean landing soon
one is the study that I've involved in
as principal investigator looking at
cannabis concentration and PTSD symptoms
so really having 7276 veterans with
treatment resistant PTSD and assigning
them you know administering the drug
giving them high THC and high CBD so
kind of like a one-to-one a high THC and
a low CBD a high CBD and a low THC so
kind of the inverse and a placebo and
here giving that to you know giving it
to them for three three weeks using ad
libs so they can really just kind of
self titrate to what works for them
after three weeks they stop we have a
washout period so we can see that sort
of the important thing right the
therapeutics on the first three weeks
and then when they stop using how do
they do right those
sort of dependence and discontinuation
the draw problems that are again really
important to look at we really need a
balanced approach when we think about
medicine and then after those two weeks
of washout then they are we randomized
to another condition which they use for
three weeks and then again two weeks of
cessation so in this study we're looking
at PTSD suicide functioning and also
like I said negative consequences so
again let's take a balanced approach to
this we really try to understand it so
that study just completed and we'll be
publishing on this year and another
study from a former postdoc of mind BA
San Diego this is the first actual study
that the Department of Veterans Affairs
has funded in the cannabinoid
administration space which is really
exciting
she's looking at 136 military veterans
with PTSD and really focusing on whether
CBD cannabidiol can be used as an
adjunct to prolonged exposure so
prolonged exposure is kind of the
primary behavioral because of the gold
standard if you will behavioral
treatment for PTSD but it has its
limitations and so can we add CBD versus
placebo right so in this randomized
controlled trial to see whether
individuals that have a sort of adjunct
of CBD do better are they able to stay
in treatment longer they able to you
know have a reduction in symptoms
quicker and we look at this with primary
outcomes like the caps 5 which is the
diagnostic standard for PTSD as well as
other secondary outcomes like the PCL
and then safety and side effects again
so this is starting actually you should
say in the shades in the spring 2019
it's been delayed and again this is your
exact
issue is that these studies are hard to
do and there's lots of Hoops and so this
study you know has been in the works
you know after receiving funding it's
taken a year to get it off the ground
and that's that's the difficulty in
doing it but you know for the
strong-willed and those with grit you
can make it through it and so that's the
you know that's pretty much it
so I'll leave it there thank you
Thank You dr. von Miller for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank laberd's for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I want to let everyone know
that this webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through June of 2019
as a refining reminder our speaker will
follow up with any questions that you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we will see
you next time goodbye